We are here with Sharon Chuter, the founder of UOMA Beauty
a company that I have been a huge fan of
for a really long time.
I can't believe I'm doing the show with you Sharon.
And we have another connection, which was
that I was lucky enough to participate in your
pull-up for change.
Yes you did.
Thank you for allowing me to that party.
Everybody jumped on board because your mission was so clear.
Why did you start the pull-up for change hashtag?
Yes, I did that really to drive, or raise more awareness,
or shine more light to the lack of economic opportunities
for the black community, especially within the beauty space.
I know we've been talking about lack of inclusivity
but it was really to shine light
at some of the root causes of this,
because really it's like, it's like a computer, right?
Whatever you put in it's what's gonna come out.
And so for me, that was really the driver
to make sure that we have a better world
where we have more economic equality
because the economic inequality in America right now
is at pandemic level.
So thank you for participating and pulling up.
Were you always such an activist?
Because your activism is so strong and powerful
and a real game changer in the industry now.
Were you always that person
or did you have a tidal wave of inspiration?
Well for me, I've always been the person
who speaks up, you know?
In my country we call it (mumbles), right.
Speak louder.
So I've always been that troublemaker.
As a kid I would get beat up all the time.
So I think from mine, I didn't even know
that was a word for it.
It's just whenever I see something that needs to change
I don't have any means to just sit it out.
And I think as people, and especially as artists,
as business people, we have,
everything we do have to be connected
to the times that we live in.
And right now we live in times of gross injustice.
So for me, it would be just odd, just go in your bag,
you know, selling lipsticks and eyeliners
and yay, people are dying and starving and you know,
there's injustice and it's like, oh, who cares?
I just wanna wear makeup, you know?
So, so I think that, there was no option you know?
Sharon, I feel the exact same way.
I try to be so positive on this show,
but I wanna talk about the pain and the reality
and the world we are living in.
And unless I'm living in reality
then I don't feel like I have the right to be positive.
So I really understand that side.
And 2020 in my opinion has been
one of the most important years in history, period.
Yes.
(lady laughing)
And I'm honored to be a part of it
and have been woken up and learned
and everything that you've done for it.
And on a completely beauty junkie level
that has nothing to do with the crucial and vital activism
that you do, and that we're all learning from,
which is your beauty brand is one of my favorites.
It's just an amazing beauty (mumbles).
I love it, it's extraordinary.
Your products, your packaging.
It's like my favorite.
I was so excited to have you on the show
go to our website at thedrewbarrymoreshow.com
to look more at Sharon's important work
in beauty and activism.
Sharon, thank you for coming on this show.
Thank you so much.
I'm such a huge fan of yours.
(upbeat music)